in the growing series of just downright
bizarre interviews that Donald Trump has
given lately he recently wondered why
the country had a civil war and also
suggested that President Andrew Jackson
could have prevented the Civil War had
he been president later than he was that
also makes no sense this it's becoming
Stranger Than Fiction this is from an
interview with the Washington examiners
Selena zido take a listen to this I mean
had Andrew Jackson been a little bit
later you would have had the Civil War
he
was he was a very tough person but he
had a big heart and he
was he was really
angry that he saw what was happening
with regard to the Civil War he said
there's no reason for this people don't
realize you know the Civil
War um yeah you think about it why
people don't ask that question but why
was there the the Civil War why could
why could that one not have been worked
out people wonder why there was a Civil
War what people what people this is this
is like Tides go in Tides go out you
can't explain that the Civil War why
nobody knows Pat everybody just wonders
bread goes into the toaster toast comes
out where'd the bread go people wonder
you can't explain it it's like he's
being philosopher Trump here and asking
the questions that no one else is
willing to ask I mean you can read a
book on this topic you can learn all
about the Missouri Compromise and
slavery's effects on the economy and the
different abolitionist movements but I
don't think he has that much curiosity
by the way did Andrew Jackson see what
was happening with the Civil War and get
angry he died in 1845 and the War Began
16 years later in 1861 what exactly did
Andrew Jackson see about the Civil War I
think Trump just has a very romanticized
view of Andrew Jackson because a lot of
people in his inner circle have compared
him to Jackson uh particularly when it
comes to the election of 1828 and the
sort of bombas and Independence that
Jackson had right but Jackson was also a
very controversial figure particularly
when it comes to the Indian Removal acts
that are known as the Trail of Tears so
maybe not the best person to draw
comparisons to well finally someone's
going to look into the causes of the
American Civil War I've been waiting for
a long time for somebody to try to look
look into that and who isn't asking the
question I mean historians for centuries
have been asking the question every
single US history class I know that
education is problematic in in a lot of
States but most US History classes
asking that question I remember having
to write in the remember those blue
lined journals that you had to write in
uh I remember writing test answers about
the causes of the Civil War and by the
way Trump is also wrong Andrew Jackson
probably would have gone into the Civil
War more than likely it's kind of
surreal when the president of the United
States is generally less informed than
your average third or fourth grade
student and for me this continues to
point in the direction of the early
signs of dementia with Donald Trump
which we've been talking about for a
while Trump is clueless but the real
damage here and I think you know where
I'm going to go with this Pat the
legitimization of anti-intellectualism
you don't need to read you don't need to
know anything about history you can be
just an uninformed vassel going through
the world and it's great and anybody who
wants to change that is some liberal
college indoctrinator or something like
that that's the undertone of this that
to me is the scariest I think it would
be very good for Donald Trump if he read
just a few presidential biographies or
at least listen to them on tape I also
wouldn't liken myself to Andrew Jackson
That's you you sort of alluded to that
Jackson ignored a supreme court order
and drove Native Americans to
reservations which resulted in countless
deaths this has sort of become for me
the parody that is no longer at all
funny and I I I was listening to this
clip yesterday in preparation for the
show and I thought this the headlines
can't possibly be right this must be an
impersonator of Donald Trump this
couldn't really be actually Donald Trump
and it is I mean this this is 2017 I
like how the person interviewing him was
trying to help him along and just kind
of let him end the analogy but he kept
going yeah he he the guy can't even help
himself other people can't help him he
certainly can't help himself and listen
if you've also been waiting around
hoping somebody would figure out why we
even had a Civil War and what the causes
were maybe Donald Trump mentioning it
will help us figure it out